you can do a lot of different things
[Music]
that way because what happens is if the
fuse pulls out a lot of people will try
to put it back in thank you
and then you can have a problem so
that's just another part of what we test
and then
um every one of these like i told you
earlier has an ex number which is it
will tell us the components of each
firework so if we want to we can get
right down to the actual ounces of the
explosives and the contents of each of
when it's these
uh
that one's not gonna make it
yeah
[Music]
that's that's some of the stuff we watch
for and that's why we test them because
if you let that off at home and you just
threw it in your trash right away you
could have a fire so
[Music]
in your opinion that does that one
no that will be a retest
and it could be just as simple as that
was a bad
you know
so that this one automatically goes to
the retest
[Music]
[Music]
hey my name is george gonzalez with the
mount charleston fire protection
district spill
j-o-r-g-e gonzales g-o-n-z-a-l-e-z
so the conditions are prime uh at any
time uh if you use uh fireworks of any
kind in southern nevada the the wet the
wet conditions are lacking here
the dry
vegetation
grass is always there present we also
recommend to the public to ensure that
they're purchasing all their fireworks
during the approved period in southern
nevada from the approved sites